Peter Bogosian is a philosophy
instructor critical thinker and author
of a manual for creating atheists
he's also an anti regressive warrior and
can back it up with some jiu-jitsu Peter
welcome to the show thank you thank you
for having me really looking forward to
our chat I am looking forward to it as
well you know every week I feel like I'm
connecting with people that I know in
the digital space mostly through 140
characters and I are you in that group
you just did three hours with Rogen I
did we had an interesting conversation
how you feeling you came up you came up
too good I feel great I know great did
you say good things about me we said
nothing well you know that's the thing
we don't I think part of it is when
people are together and they're sincere
I think they'll they'll either agree or
disagree or there'll be a convergence
around those ideas and I started off
when we were talking thinking that I
feel like I know you like I feel that
the stuff that you think about and the
values that you have are in congruence
with my own values and I think part of
that comes from from a type of honesty
with oneself yeah well we're obviously
going to talk a lot about those values
and I think it really is cool that this
this group of people have come together
you were sort of in this a little bit
before me and connected with Sam and
some of those other guys but now rogue
in christina hoff sommers all these
people who don't necessarily agree on
everything don't come from the same
walks of life or the same socio-economic
sever whatever that we've all sort of
come together because we have these base
principles ups that we want to put out
there yeah I think that's right and I
think that it's so so here's one way to
think about it we often think about the
right and the left on some kind of a
line so there's the far right which is
obviously on the far right of the line
the far left and the middle this is in
philosophy there's a French philosopher
has this idea of a horseshoe theory you
take the ends of the line and you bend
them together the far left and the far
right are closer to each other than they
are to the center yeah and so I think
that that's a helpful heuristic or
helpful way to look at some of these
issues and
for me it was you know rather than give
a genealogical account about how this
came to be
for me what's always interesting is when
I look at the mean-spiritedness the
anger the tactics of the regresses
they're just so fundamentally contrary
to what my values are and for the sort
of person that I want to become yeah
yeah and and I do see that that
horseshoe that far left and that far
right and in the left the regressive
seem extraordinarily angry and eager to
smear those people with racist sexist
homophobic cetera if you don't buy into
certain even if you ask questions as
opposed to buying into something they've
made any kind of discourse almost
impossible yeah well we've talked a
little bit about that and I Sam said
something Sam Harris said something
about how it's almost like scorched
earth yeah
loosely quoting what he said because the
tactics have been so bad but before we
get into all that let's talk about you a
little bit so people can understand
where you come from all this and and the
book that you've written which I just
read this week a manual for creating
atheist it was it was wonderful it was
it was what I try to do here at which I
guess goes to what you said at the top
because it was understandable you were
trying to give people the tools to go
about talking about you know reasoning
and morality without taking the leap of
faith yeah and and asking people starts
off and so thank you for the the book
you enjoyed the book I fully did all
right really did and if you didn't you
tell me I absolutely look a so that's
the type of sincerity and I'd appreciate
that so so the the book talks about in
the forthcoming app atheist which talks
about how to have more civil productive
conversations with people to help them
break through dogmatism to help them
break through these deep-seated beliefs
that they hold and that they think that
they're better people because they hold
these beliefs so how to really have
productive conversations and engage
people yeah so I think the best way to
jump off on this is let's just define
some terms and I've done this in one
incarnation or another a few times on
the show when we've talked about
religion and atheism and agnosticism and
all that but why don't you just give me
some basic definitions which is sort of
how you start the book so
is what is an atheist so the way I
define atheist I think it's right these
are placeholder terms I'm willing to
revise those I don't have an atheist as
a person who doesn't have sufficient
evidence to warrant belief in God but if
they were given that evidence than they
would believe so inherent in the term
atheist or the way that I use it is a
sort of open-mindedness right which is
funny to me and that's the way you
describe it in the book
because there seems to be a certain
subset of people that think that
atheists are actually the most
close-minded people but that's not the
way you're defining it maybe that's just
sort of the personalities that have been
publicly attached to atheism or
something to a certain extent we we can
understand why someone would think that
because the word theist is contained
with the word atheist and just as
theists tend to have these dogmas where
they latch on to religious propositions
faith propositions to faith so - one
would think that a theist does but again
I think that the faithful have
constructed these narratives - to make
it as if there's some kind of a
parallelism a symmetry of belief look we
believe these things you guys believe it
we we have beliefs that are predicated
on no evidence just like you do right
and I I I think that's a type of
insincerity I don't think that people
who are honest with themselves and have
a minimal level and you know basically
enough intelligence to tie a shoe a shoe
is I don't think that it's possible to
come to that conclusion yeah so so
before we go too deep on that what are
the other what are the other terms we
should just define right at the
beginning so agnosticism for example I
would you don't you're not big on no I
don't like that yeah I don't like the
term I think it's a it's a useless
tournament we need to do away with it
you you don't believe in Santa Claus no
so you were a Santa Clause atheist we
don't understand - Claus agnostic right
so the word agnostic is gives wiggle
room where no wiggle room should exist
the default to any belief shouldn't be
maybe the default should probably be no
unless I have sufficient evidence to
believe right but again that's part of
the hijacking of the the narrative right
so that's interesting so a lot of people
I've heard
lately they describe themselves as
agnostic atheists yeah that seems to be
like the new murmured Arab you heard
about that one where it give them I
guess a little more wiggle room but
you're saying that that the way that's
sort of cheating the the idea here right
yeah it may be people self-described
that way because they feel they want to
reap some social benefits from it maybe
they feel that they don't want to offend
people or insult people or make people
feel bad that they use these wiggle
terms yeah so in the book well first up
is there anything else we should define
just real quick right I don't know I
don't think so but if uh if we've
defined something and it's your right
it's important to define words and those
can be placeholders for later on because
if someone says I'm an agnostic atheist
I'll say well what do you mean by that
and I can challenge or what-have-you but
if not it's like two ships passing a
[ __ ] other than that like we don't know
what the conversation is about and there
was a lot of that in the book were you
talking about you know people with faith
and people without faith or not a
non-believer versus believer would
however you wanted to find it yeah
they're they're talking about two
different things and that sometimes
makes the conversation really kind of
crazy it does and that's the problem
with faith is that it has a broad
semantic range and people try to use the
term to do some work that it doesn't do
yeah like they try to use the term to
protect like well I believe that
Muhammad flu having a winged horse or I
believe Jesus walked in water or you
know fasting or the Dali Lama incarnated
through bodies where it but I just you
have faith your wife loves you or you
have faith in a plan so they use that
term as an umbrella term to almost cover
their beliefs from any make it
impervious to reason and I just don't
think that's that's a very sincere way
to approach any inquiry right so I think
a lot of people just from this first
five or six minutes we're gonna say
about this guy this guy's a pretty
open-minded atheist like that that's
going to be part of it and I think one
of the things you said right at the
beginning of the book is you don't
really define yourself as an atheist and
I thought you reaiiy thought your
reasoning was actually really clever can
you go into that it would but you tell
me what you got and then I'll well
basically you were saying I don't define
myself as someone that doesn't believe
in leprechaun
Yeah right right so but but yet there
seems to be with atheist there seems to
be so much onus on them to constantly
have to talk about it or whatever it is
I've only been in this kind I never even
publicly said that I was an atheist yeah
I heard you so literally it was about
two months ago I think when my lolly
innopolis was on the show I always
considered myself sort of a friend of
the Atheist community I always liked
atheist I like free thinkers I like
critical thinkers it never it wasn't
something that really hit me one way or
another I didn't feel like I needed to
say all right I have to yeah make this
announcement or this announcement but
somehow in that conversation with him I
had finally sort of got to my breaking
point or something well that was good
then it was a good cover so yeah it was
all good look honesty though yeah public
honesty and so I think that the word
atheist still has some negative
connotations and a lot of negativity is
attached to it but I don't I think that
atheism is a conclusion and it's
ultimately it's much less important that
then epistemological hygiene if you were
like thinking about how you come to
knowledge and making sure that that that
those ways to come to knowledge are
reliable because that's the other thing
that was a big realization for me a long
time ago is that that faith faith claims
or knowledge claims so when someone
makes a faith claim they're making a
claim about the world like I have faith
because of X so people use faith as a
process to get to a claim about the
world I mean the whole thing is just so
bizarre
yeah twisted but unfortunately where we
live it's surrounded surrounding us but
I don't I don't have it's weird to me
like I'll go to I'll speak in atheist
conference and people be singing about
being atheist society it's just I can't
it's just unfathomable right well that's
why your description of it felt decent
to me you know an immediate certainly as
I said I didn't talk about him till 3
months ago it's never I don't think it
will ever be something that defines me
what defines me are my thoughts and my
the breath of all the things that I am
but that's just to define yourself by
saying you don't believe in actually
doesn't make that much sense right yeah
and I'm trying to think about defining
yourself in terms of your thought I
don't even know if I'd do that I mean I
think it's important to ask yourself
what kind of person do you want to be
yeah like you know I want to be a kind
person I want to be a compassionate
person
I am very confident that those values
are derived both through reason and that
we can articulate ways to get through
those very clearly but I'm not I'm not
sure if it maybe I'm wrong you know
maybe my onething about maybe I want to
be the type of person who's willing to
revise my beliefs maybe I want to be the
type of person who's inquisitive and
trustful of reason and who treats people
well you know maybe that's the kind of
person I want to become so maybe those
things are identify self identify with
those but I don't it's just an odd thing
to me to latch that on to an identity
yeah well I certainly agree with that so
a lot of what you're doing in the book
is really and I think you actually use
this word is to deprogram you know from
faith and I thought using that word was
particularly interesting because you're
viewing it as sort of you know we all
enter this this life sort of as a clean
slate and then we're programmed with
this stuff and you're trying to give
everyone the tools to to deprogram yeah
that's exactly right we we've been
indoctrinated by ideas culture we have
everybody as a kind of cultural myopia
that's reinforced by religion and
beliefs so how do we help people to
become more reflective about their
beliefs how do we help people to become
less dogmatic about what they about
their thoughts and and you know maybe
that's why I like for me even the
sexuality isn't part of an identity but
maybe that's because it's a dominant a
heteronormative manner you know so I
mean I I don't I don't know what I do
know is that people think that having
certain beliefs makes them a better
person Dan debt talks about this in
terms of belief and belief and part of
the problem is once you start thinking
that you're holding beliefs makes you a
better person you're much less likely to
revise those because it moves from the
realm of the pistil mala ji that is
knowledge to the realm of morals and you
don't want to be that guy like you don't
want to be yeah yeah no I'm with you the
difference between knowledge and morals
which people seem to conflate constantly
right yeah and it's interesting in terms
of the
the regressive left and the the idea of
race when people talk about race that is
just so charged and so politicized that
they have made it almost impossible for
a sincere Enquirer to ask a question
without being smeared or labelled in
some way yeah and we've lost the ability
we've lost the ability in an academic
context to ask sincere questions so that
we could the only way to solve any
problem the first step is to be honest
about if you're not honest about it
you're not going to solve it and you've
written about this and Douglas Mari was
on Sam's podcast other people have
spoken about so I've tweeted about this
and I wrote about this if you do not
allow questions then extremists are
eager to come in with answers yeah and
so that's one of the consequences that
we see and we see this in a religious
landscape very especially with Islam now
we mean we see this terrible problem
you